(audience cheers)
- [Conan] My guests tonight
are the stars and creators
of the Emmy Award winning
HBO series "Game of Thrones".
Please welcome Executive
Producers, D.B. Weiss,
David Benioff, and from
the cast, Iwan Rheon,
Conleth Hill, Nathalie
Emmanuel, (inaudible),
Liam Cunningham, John
Bradley, Kristian Nairn,
Isaac Hempstead Wright.
There you go, I had to get them all out.
Thank you.
So cool, how ya doin'?
How are ya?
Thank you for being here.
Hey, good to see ya, how are you?
(applause)
Well, that's nice. (laughs)
Well, that's all the time we have.
Thank you so much.
You know there's one
mistake I made last year,
I am not gonna make it again.
Last year, Liam, I ran
out of time before I got
to ask you a question.
It bothered me very much,
so I'm going to start
with you this year.
Okay, how about that?
How do you feel about that, Liam?
(applause)
- Good move, dude.
- Good move?
- Oh yeah, I got a
blunt machete backstage.
You were gonna lose a limb
if you didn't talk to me.
(laughs)
- Stop glowering at me, for God's sake.
All right, I gotta ask you, Liam,
you have lasted five seasons.
What is the secret to not getting killed
on "Game of Thrones"?
What is it?
(applause)
- All right, let me
tell you, those two boys
down the end there have
got a sick sense of humor.
- Yeah.
- They're like the, you can compare them
to the heads of the five
families in New York.
- Right, right.
- You get a phone call to go to dinner.
- Right.
- You don't come back from that dinner.
(laughs)
So, the trick is, don't make eye contact,
don't pick up the phone.
- Don't pick up the phone,
don't make eye contact,
don't talk to them, very, very wise.
How would you like to see Davos go,
when he goes, how would
you like to see him go?
- Well, I've made a couple of suggestions.
I think he should go to Dorne,
he should drink some vintage Dornish wine
in the company of a couple
of hookers and an eight ball.
(laughs)
(applause)
I'm not sure what an
eight ball is but there.